yesterday a federal district court judge
in DC John debates overturned president
Trump's decision to end the daca program
the judge was appointed by george w bush
ruled that trumps action was arbitrary
and capricious because the Department of
Homeland Security failed adequately to
explain its conclusion that the program
was unlawful
well this judge ordered the
administration to continue to accept new
daca applicants but he's delaying the
implementation for 90 days so that the
Trump folks can rewrite their basis for
ending daca now if this ruling stands it
could actually mean the tripling of the
number of illegals ultimately protected
by this Obama era program daca would
then be open to an additional 1.2
million more people according to an
analysis by the migration policy
institute and that's on top of the
nearly 700,000 already protected by the
program the very idea that one unelected
district court judge could have this
type of power should outrage every
American I don't think any serious legal
scholar really thinks that President
Obama had the constitutional authority
to waive his noble hand and grant 700
thousand young people de-facto
citizenship I mean remember he gave them
the right to work here without fear of
any deportation all by this executive
action and remember when the Democrats
had the majority in Congress they failed
to pass broad-based amnesty so Obama
through his Homeland Security Secretary
Janet Napolitano decided he's gonna do
it on his own and this was done despite
the misgivings of his own Justice
Department but nevertheless Obama pushed
it as far as he could the bill hasn't
really changed the need hasn't changed
it's still the right thing to do the
only thing that has changed apparently
was the politics it makes no sense to
expel talented young people
who for all intents and purposes are
Americans yeah that whole citizenship
thing all those millions of people who
came here legally to get citizenship
that's all a formality mr. president
what President Trump and his
administration did by rescinding daca
was to actually restore the rule of law
and return immigration decisions and the
fate of those daca kids to the
constitutionally appropriate branch of
government Congress yet district court
judges from San Francisco to Brooklyn
and now here in Washington DC have
stymied this president at every turn
this is totally absurd and an abuse of
power now you might be asking yourself
how we got here and how do we get to a
point where people from foreign
countries believe that they can crash
our borders game our immigration system
and then ultimately just wander freely
in our country well the answer one
out-of-control judge in California had a
lot to do with it her name is judge
dolly key and in 2014 we saw remember a
mass influx of illegals crossing our
southwest border and remember the Obama
Department of Homeland Security placed a
lot of those illegal immigrant family
units in detention facilities well in
2015
judge he ruled that the government could
not detain the children in centers set
up all those centers set up in Texas
because the judge ruled they were not
safe and sanitary enough and she based
that decision on this 1997 settlement
agreement it was called the Flores case
that required that unaccompanied alien
minors be released into the country
without delay and this judge key went
even further ruling that not only should
the minors be released into the United
States once apprehended but their
parents should be allowed to go free as
well so again that one district judge in
California is responsible for the
release of an estimated one hundred and
seven thousand unaccompanied minors
to the interior of this country since
the Year 2016 and then also most of the
167,000 apprehended family units
released as well again think this
through one district court judge has
forever changed our cultural demographic
and economic perhaps national security
landscape one judge that is not what our
founders intended now let's face it the
runaway judiciary has become in effect
and new flank of the resistance they're
taking away your power and it's time for
Congress to circumscribe the authority
and the reach of these district court
judges think about national health care
policy immigration policy national
security these matters are all beyond
the scope and understanding frankly of a
district court judge it's like giving a
local mayor control over US foreign
policy it's ridiculous remember the
Constitution article 3 section 1 states
the following the judicial power of the
United States shall be vested in one
Supreme Court and in such inferior
courts as the Congress may from time to
time ordain and establish and it
continued now what does that mean that
means the Congress can regulate the
lower court's jurisdiction and it's time
they do in fact they've done so in the
past Congress should immediately pass
legislation establishing that any cases
touching on important national security
or national economic concerns should be
referred to the appeals courts or the
Supreme Court directly without delay or
at the very least constitutional
determinations of the type we're seeing
in this docket case they should be
referred to the appellate judges
three-judge panel or maybe even the
ombak panel of the whole court they're
far more knowledgeable in constitutional
matters and far more knowledgeable on
all these matters god bless them then
the district court judges the tyranny
especially of the district court bench
has to end and the people's will should
no longer be held hostage to the
capricious whims of
one ill-equipped disgruntled life
tenured jurist and that's the angle